d'alluré n'en soit pas trop je crois que
j'ai un problème d'addiction abondent à
quoi à l'eau pétillante
quoi bailly perd souvent se ressent un
besoin violent et je peux pas empêcher
d'en prendre à ta soif donc tu bois en
fait tu crois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous connaissez sûrement des gens qui
racontent plus ou moins affirmant qu'ils
sont accro au chocolat addict au café à
l'amour ou je sais pas quoi
alors loin de moi l'idée de douter de la
bonne foi de vos amis mais est ce qu'on
peut vraiment être addict à tout et
n'importe quoi pour répondre à cette
question que vous vous posez peut-être
pas il ya cinq minutes mais dont vous
brûlez maintenant de connaître la
réponse vu que vous êtes addict au
savoir et à la connaissance
il faut d'abord comprendre ce que c'est
en vrai une addiction pendant longtemps
on parlait juste de drogue alors déjà à
la base il faut savoir que drogue ça
voulais juste dire médicaments et puis
le mot a été détournée de son sens pour
désigner une substance susceptible
d'entraîner une toxicomanie c'est à dire
une consommation compulsive avec une
dépendance ça hallyday essentiellement
les produits illicites comme le cannabis
la cocaïne l'héroïne etc
et puis on s'est vite rendu compte qu'en
réalité ça concernait aussi des
substances légales comme le tabac ou
l'alcool
et puis les connaissances en la matière
se sont encore un peu affiné et
aujourd'hui on peut se dire qu'en
réalité dans l'absolu parler de drogue
ça arrive plus à grand chose
du coup on peut aussi oublié le concept
de drogues dures drogues douces qui veut
pas dire grand chose non plus si c'est
une drogue et peut pas être douce et si
elle est douce c'est pas une drogue
voyez ça a jamais été hyper clair du
coup on parle plutôt d'addiction parce
que c'est plus pertinent de se
concentrer sur nos comportements et les
conséquences qu'ils ont à tous les
niveaux de notre vie que sur ce qu'on
consomme pour comprendre ce que c'est
une addiction on va commencer par la
base
qu'est ce qui se passe dans notre corps
quand on prend ou quand on fait un truc
qui nous fait du bien pour nous inciter
à faire les trucs importants pour notre
survie ou celle de notre espèce genre
boire manger et nous reproduire et c'est
notre cerveau il a une petite technique
assez maligne une technique qu'on
utilise nous mêmes dans la vie de tous
les jours vous allez voir il nous
récompense en nous faisant plaisir quand
on fait un truc bien ça s'appelle même
le système de récompense justement en
gros quand on mange ou qu'on a un
rapport sexuel ça active la production
de certains neurotransmetteurs qui sont
des substances chimiques qui vont se
fixer sur des récepteurs précis de nos
neurones et déclenché une réaction
dans le cas qui nous intéresse il ya
plusieurs neurotransmetteur qui entrent
en jeu
mais le principal c'est la dopamine
à meuse alors de trucs d'abord la
dopamine
c'est pas du tout une hormone c'est un
neurotransmetteur et puis son rôle c'est
plutôt de stimuler le désir
donc oui elles activent le système de
récompense et ça procure effectivement
du plaisir mais ça c'est grâce à
l'intervention d'autres
neurotransmetteurs comme les endorphines
la sérotonine ou l'ocytocine mais bref
au bout du compte le principe s'est vu
que ça fait du bien on a envie de
recommencer
là je vous la fait courte mais je vous
mets dans la description un lien vers
une vidéo qui explique ça de façon plus
détaillée
si ça vous intéresse le problème c'est
que certaines substances déclenché une
grosse production de dopamine ça dérègle
le circuit de la récompense
et ça crée une dépendance et un
mécanismes neurobiologiques qui entrent
en jeu dans l'addiction
mais attention ça suffit pas pour
l'expliquer complètement parce qu'on
n'est pas tous égaux face à ce phénomène
tout est pas juste une histoire de
réactions chimiques
la preuve on sait maintenant qu'il ya
des addictions n'ont rien à voir avec
ces substances
mais avec aucune substance en fait
d'ailleurs comme les gens sont astucieux
ils appellent ça des addictions sans
substance ou des addictions
comportementales pour le moment il ya
une seule pratique est officiellement
reconnue comme une addiction par le
manuel diagnostique et statistique des
troubles mentaux
le dsm 5 qu'est le document de référence
en la matière et cette pratique serre
les jeux de hasard et d'argent donc pas
les jeux vidéo ou les smartphones par
exemple ni le sexe alors qu'il ya de
plus en plus d'experts qu'il se penche
sérieusement sur la question et qui
propose des thérapies
donc attention c'est pas parce qu'ils
sont pas dans la liste qui peut pas y
avoir d'addiction ils sont juste pas
dans la liste
ou pas encore parce que c'est le genre
de choses qui évoluent en même temps que
la société
bref tout ça n'empêche pas que même dans
les addictions sans substance le fameux
système de récompense il joue un rôle
aussi mais globalement quel que soit
l'objet d'une addiction
il ya aussi des critères psychologiques
comportementaux des répercussions
sociales etc
mais on va voir ça tout de suite pour
faire simple quand on parle d'addiction
on parle d'une souffrance c'est un
trouble mental c'est pas juste le fait
de beaucoup aimer un truc si vous pouvez
pas vous empêcher de finir la tablette
de chocolat quand vous l'avez entamé sa
fait pas de vous un ou une addict au
chocolat éprouvé un immense plaisir en
faisant quelque chose au point qu'on a
envie de le faire le plus souvent
possible
c'est pas ça être a dit c'est pas non
plus la quantité ou la fréquence à
laquelle vont consommer un produit qui
fait de vous un ou une addict ni le fait
que le produit soit mauvais pour la
santé ou pas formés là en fait on a vu
ce que ça n'est pas l'addiction
donc on va voir un peu ce que c'est
l'addiction comme je voulais dit c'est
un trouble mental qui entraîne une
souffrance liée à une dépendance et qui
a des conséquences négatives sur votre
vie mais encore et là il ya des critères
précis qui ont été établis par les
spécialistes pour savoir si oui ou non
vous êtes addict
la première c'est la perte de contrôle
vous n'arrivez pas à vous empêcher de
consommer le produit ou de faire
l'activité qui est en cause vous arrivez
pas arrêté ensuite il ya ce besoin
violent que vous ressentez régulièrement
cette envie irrépressible de consommer
qui vous envahissent on appelle ça le
craving aux critères vous continuez
alors que vous avez conscience que vous
devriez arrêter parce que ça a des
conséquences négatives survenu bon ces
trois là c'est les plus évidents et les
plus connus j'imagine qu'ils vont me
surprennent pas trop surtout si vous
mais par exemple mais il y en a deux
autres qui sont un petit peu plus pointu
d'abord il ya ce qu'on appelle le
phénomène de tolérance plus ça va plus
vous êtes obligés d'augmenter les doses
pour arriver au même résultat
c'est à dire pour soulager ce besoin
irrépressible et la souffrance qui va
avec
et enfin il ya le syndrome de sevrage
quand vous pouvez pas consommer vous
êtes mal physiquement psychologiquement
voir les deux et ça s'arrête dès que
vous reprenez votre consommation
donc oui c'est ce qu'on appelle le
manque et il faut savoir que cela se
manifeste pas de la même façon selon les
produits et il faut aussi savoir un truc
dont on parle peu c'est qu'on peut
mourir d'un syndrome de sevrage à
l'alcool avec le chocolat il ya un
moindre et donc là on a les bases pour
définir une addiction
on a les contours si vous voulez mais
dans le dsm 5 dont je vous ai parlé tout
à l'heure il ya aussi onze points qui
permettent de définir non seulement si
vous avez une addiction
mais surtout si c'est le cas de
déterminer si elle est faible moyenne ou
sévère sait on ce point il se base sur
ce qu'on vient de dire mais il entre un
peu plus dans le détail des conséquences
concrètes de votre consommation sur
votre vie quotidienne
en fait au niveau conjugale sociale
professionnelle etc
plutôt que de vous les énumérer je vais
vous proposer un truc je vous mets ici
là quelque part et dans la description
de la vidéo un lien vers un test qui
reprend ses onze critères sous forme de
questions et à la fin du cou qui nous
apporte la réponse vraiment faite le
c'est important parce que autant il ya
des gens qui se proclament accro à plein
de trucs alors que non autant on peut
souffrir d'une addiction et ne pas en
avoir conscience
on en avait déjà parlé au sujet de
l'alcool d'ailleurs je vous remets les
liens dans la description et quand on a
un problème la base pour le régler c'est
d'être au courant comme on a donc j'ai
pas d'ordre à vous donner mais
franchement
allez-y faites le test mais bon alors
pour répondre à la question de départ
est-ce qu'on peut être addict à tous ben
non déjà parce que on l'a vu une
addiction c'est un trouble avec des
caractéristiques bien précises c'est pas
juste le fait de beaucoup aimer un truc
est de le faire beaucoup et très souvent
on parle pas d'un plaisir qu'on a envie
de se faire on parle d'une souffrance
qu'on a besoin de soulager ensuite dans
une moindre mesure bas parce qu'il ya
une liste établie de
produit et d'activités qui peuvent
entraîner une addiction
mais bon elle est amenée à évoluer donc
la vérité d'aujourd'hui mêmes d'hier en
fait parce que le dsm sein qui date de
2013 n'est pas forcément celle de demain
dans les trucs à retenir il ya aussi un
truc important on peut consommer du
cannabis de l'alcool ou de la cocaïne
sans développer une addiction par contre
on peut être addict aux jeux d'argent
alors que la grande majorité des gens
qui jouent ne le sont pas mais attention
quand même garder deux trucs à l'esprit
d'abord les substances dont on parle ça
reste quand même des substances toxiques
même sens addiction et puis il ya des
substances qui sont plus susceptibles
que les autres de vous rendre addict
donc je suis pas votre merde mais le
mieux c'est quand même ne pas tenter le
diable juste pour info les substances
qui sont potentiellement les plus
addictives c'est dans l'ordre le tabac
l'héroïne la cocaïne
l'alcool et le cannabis dernière chose
vous avez vu on peut consommer ou faire
quelque chose de manière intensive sans
pour autant que ce soit une addiction
donc pour ça comme pour tout le reste
au passage l'autodiagnostic on oublie
donc faites le test
dans un premier temps et en fonction des
résultats
ah si besoin par les ans à un médecin
dans un deuxième temps alors vous allez
me dire où l'on joue sur les mots là en
fait
manon on joue pas les mots c'est
important est le fait de dire qu'on est
addict pour un oui ou pour un non
ça minimise le fait de souffrir
réellement d'une addiction et en
l'occurrence employés le bon mot pour
décrire ce qu'on a ça permet de savoir
ce qu'il faut faire pour s'en sortir
c'est à dire aller voir un spécialiste
je vous mets un lien dans la description
pour en trouver un près de chez vous si
besoin
parce qu'encore une fois être addict
c'est une souffrance et ça soigne
voilà à détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien mais pas n'importe
comment et surtout
pour tenir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]